hi everyone
thank you so much for attending our last
keynote for the cell and developmental
biology virtual meeting
i want to also thank our last keynote
speaker
claire brown for uh joining us today and
giving
um and giving her presentation claire
has worked in the field of quantitative
bio imaging for over 25 years
her research has focused on applying
biophysical techniques to fluorescent
microscopy images
to extract quantitative data measuring
protein distributions
dynamics and interaction interactions
she applies these techniques to study
the regulation of cell adhesion and
migration
to understand how migration is regulated
at the molecular level in normal and
diseased
cellular systems her work has also
focused on optimizing
live cell imaging to minimize photo
toxicity
and ensure the collection of high
fidelity data that is free of light
induced artifacts she's been
the director of the advanced bioimaging
facility
abif for for 15 years excuse me
and developing and implementing active
learning courses and workshops
in fundamental and advanced light
microscopy
and last but not least claire takes part
in several other groups and
organizations
with the aim of furthering the use of
microscopy in the life sciences and
she'll talk a little bit about that at
the end
after the q a so i also want to remind
everyone
that we will be taking questions through
the talk
during the talk so go ahead and enter
those into the
q a box for us so that we can go ahead
and get those lined up
for claire at the end of her
presentation
so thank you again claire for joining us
and i'll turn it over to you
thanks everybody
so it's a pleasure to be here this
afternoon and tell you a bit about our
project
on lipoma preferred partner or lpp and
how it regulates breast cancer cell
migration and invasion
so breast cancer accounts for
approximately 25 percent of all new
cases of cancer
and that accounts for 13 of cancer
deaths in canadian women
one in eight women are expected to
develop breast cancer during their
lifetime
and one in 33 will die as a result of
the disease
in general people don't die from the
breast cancer directly from the primary
tumor
but they die from the metastatic cancer
so breast cancer in particular tends to
metastasize to the brain
the lungs the liver and the bone and
this process has a number of different
steps
starting from the primary tumor where
the cells
invade the basement membrane travel
through the tissue
interversate into the bloodstream where
they can travel throughout the body
they can then extrapolate out of the
bloodstream and migrate to
different regions of different organs
and metastasize
historically cancer treatments have
aimed to kill the cancer cells
but if we can inhibit cell migration and
invasion then we have
viable targets for cancer treatments and
potentially new therapeutics
so we really want to to find ways to
inhibit metastases
and in order to do this we need to
understand the molecular mechanisms at
play in regulating these different steps
i'm going to tell you today about two
different
structures and and how the lpp protein
is playing a role in regulating them so
the first structure is the
focal adhesion which is a structure
which links the
cell to its extracellular matrix through
contacts between the cytoskeleton and
integrand receptors that
that bind to the ecm or the
extracellular matrix
and i'm also going to talk about in beta
podia which are
structures which invade perpendicular to
the cell down
into the extracellular matrix and
degrade the tissue and push through so
that the cells
can invade different tissues the
diploma preferred partner lpp is a
protein
that we've been interested in studying
it's 80 kilodaltons and belongs to the
vixen family
it's involved in spatial control of
actin assembly and mechanal transaction
and it interacts with number of
different proteins that both cell cell
contacts and focal adhesions are cell
matrix contacts
it has the proline rich region with an
alpha tin and binding domain that
i'll tell you more about after it
localizes two
adhesions in response to tgf beta growth
factor treatment
and this localization is dependent on
one of the limb domains
lim1
so the reason we've been interested in
lpp is that it's been linked to
metastatic cancer
and this is work done by my
collaborative lab
peter siegel at the goodman cancer
center at mcgill
and what they've been able to show is if
they inject breast cancer cells
into the fat pad of mice they grow
memory tumors
and these tumors grow over time
and this tumor growth is not impacted by
lpp
so if the cells are injected with an lpp
knockdown the tumor growth
is unchanged however importantly the
metastatic burden of the animal is
changed
so in normal conditions with lpp
present the tumor cells metastasized to
the lung and you can see
from these histological stains a huge
tumor burden
in the lung of the animal however when
lpp is knocked down that tumor burden is
much reduced and you see very few
regions in the lung in addition if you
look in the bloodstream
at circulating tumor cells they're quite
prevalent
in controlled situations where lpp is
expressed
but when lpp is knocked down you don't
see very many circulating tumor cells
so lpp is not affecting tumor growth but
it's implicated
in the ability of the cells to get into
the bloodstream and also
to get into organs at sites and
metastasis
we were interested in understanding at
the cellular level how
ltp might be regulating this process
so we looked at lpp role in cell
migration
so these are individual cells which are
plated
on fiber nectar and coated dishes and
we track them over time using bright
field imaging and then we calculate
cell tracts for each cell in the blue
here you see
tracking of cells under normal
conditions and in the red
is the cell movement after growth factor
treatment
and you can see that the cells move
faster and further following the growth
factor treatment
under conditions where the lpp protein
has been knocked down even with growth
factor treatment
the cells cannot increase in their cell
speed so this dependence
on lpp for tgf beta induced
migration it's there in addition
um you can see here the blocks showing
the lpp knockdown
and you can see um that we have this in
enhanced cell migration dependent on the
tgs data treatment
the lpp is also a time dependent process
so you can see that we have this
time lapse data shown here
and as we treat with cgf data you can
see a gradual increase in the cell
migration speed and we reach a plateau
around
15 to 18 hours after treatment
whereas again in the knockdown cells we
don't see any increase in cell migration
over time
so we were interested in looking at in
more detail at the molecular level
what's going on in the cell
so we're interested in looking at cell
adhesion
and this is a movie showing uh cells
expressing a paxillin gfp protein
paxon is an adapter protein that's known
to localize to the adhesion
and you can see that these structures
are very dynamic they're assembling and
disassembling
there's different sizes different shapes
they're
present all across the cell and there's
very tight regulation
both in time and space across the cell
and
how are these structures playing a role
in regulating cell movement
so if we look at the cell when when
cells migrate they basically have to
assemble adhesions and attach to the
extracellular matrix at the front
this usually happens through nascent
focal adhesions that are very dynamic
and can develop into intermediate focal
adhesions that are a little bit larger
and more
well developed and these create an
attachment
to the surface and force can be
generated to pull the cell forward
at that time the cell the adhesions at
the rear of the cell need to disassemble
in order to release the attachment and
allow the whole cell to process forward
so we're interested in understanding
these different structures
and their dynamics
so there's also three-dimensional
organization so this is a cartoon of an
individual one of these structures so if
we look
it would be one of these single
structures in the south and the
molecular organization there
so we have um the integrin which is
linking
the extracellular matrix to the
cytoplasmic side of the cell these are
transmembrane proteins
we have an integrand signaling layer
this is where paxillin and a number of
other proteins are
kinases phosphatases things that are
regulated and controlling downstream
signaling in the cell there's a forced
transduction layer which consists of a
lot of structural proteins such as
vinculin and talin that are linking
the adhesion to the actin cytoskeleton
and then there's an actin regulatory
layer which contains proteins such as
vixen and we believe
lpp would be in this layer since it's in
the vixen family
and just to mention that we're only
showing nine of the over 200 proteins
that have been implicated in adhesions
in this diagram so these are highly
complex and organized structures
that we need to further understand
so the goal is to identify and track the
adhesions at the leading edge so this is
a
these are areas that are protruding and
you can see these dynamic adhesions
this is a zoom in of this area here and
we used a marath surfaces feature in
order to identify these adhesions
track them over time and measure their
intensities
and from those intensities we can then
measure the dynamics of the adhesions
and
understand that those dynamics are
playing a role in regulating some
migration
with a quantified adhesion dynamics we
export the intensity data to excel
we have matlab code that was custom
designed
in the lab by alex keepass who was the
lead on this project
and were able to identify disassembly
stability and assembly events as the
adhesions
grow and disassemble and change over
time and
from these different events we can look
at a
semi-log plot of the data and calculate
the rate of disassembly and the rate of
assembly
from those plots
so this data shows lpp
each spot is a rate
for a single event so it could be an
adhesion they assemble and disassemble
so that would be
two spots on the curve an adhesion they
assemble and stabilize and then further
assemble that would be two assembly
events
so each dot here is an individual event
and if we look at just
control conditions we can measure the
assembly and disassembly and you see
this large distribution
of rape these measurements were done
with paxillin
as the readout of the adhesion so it's
not looking at lpp directly but at
excellent as a readout
of the adhesion
so when the cells are treated with tgf
beta what we see is an increase in both
the rate of assembly and the rate of
disassembly
so in general the adhesions are much
more dynamic
if we look at cells where ltp has been
knocked down
then they can't respond to the tgf beta
so similar to cell migration
the dynamics of the adhesion is not
increased
if we take those knockdown cells and
rescue them with gfp
lpp wild type then we can actually
regain the phenotype
and the cells can respond again to tgf
data
so we know that lpp is playing a role
in regulating the adhesion dynamics we
wanted to explore the protein in more
detail
so we have a mutant um lppm1
which is mutated in the m1 domain so
that it can't localize the focal
adhesion
and we have a second mutant delta abd
that has a mutation in the alpha actin
and binding domain
so that lpp can't link the adhesion to
the cytoskeleton
so when we go back to the cell migration
experiments you can see here
when we rescue the cells with lpp wild
type we see that the
from the red curves here that after
growth after treatment the cells speed
up
and you can see the time course again
here at the bottom
however if we try to rescue with the
mlm1 which can't localize two adhesions
we don't see a response to the growth
factor
and similarly if the lpp can't bind to
the actin cytoskeleton
we don't see a response to the growth
factor
similarly if we look at the adhesion
dynamic experiments
you see again if we rescue the knockdown
cells with lpp wild type we see that
response where the adhesions are more
highly dynamic
whereas when we have the inability to
localize the adhesion or the inability
to bind to actin or alpha actinin
to actin then we are unable to see a
response to the growth factor
so this really points to lp localization
to the adhesion
and lpp interaction with the actin
cytoskeleton
in order to regulate the dynamics of the
adhesion and regulate cell migration
but we were also interested in the
mechanical properties of the adhesion so
we used this
fret biosensor for tension so the way
this sensor is designed is we have an
mto fluorescent protein conjugated to a
venous fluorescent protein
and there's an elastic linker between
them when the protein is not under
tension the elastic linker is relaxed
and the teal fluorescent protein can
transfer energy to the venus
in the form of fret or fluorescence
resonance energy transfer
when the protein is under tension the
elastic linker is expanded
the teal and the venus move further
apart and the efficiency of fret is
lower
this linker is on a vinculin
is conjugated to vinculin the vinculin
head domain which binds to
the adhesion and the vinculin tail
domain which binds to actin
so we can measure tension across
individual adhesions
the experiment here shows the breast
cancer cells
expressing the sensor so we have the
teal signal and the fret signal
and based on those two signals we can
calculate a fret map
or a tension map and what we find is
when we treat with
tgs data the adhesions have much higher
tension
so the lower fret and higher tension so
the red here corresponds to high tension
low fret
and the blue to low tension for high fat
the treatment with growth factor causes
an increase in tension
but is this dependent on lpp so we have
our control
knockdown cells and then we have control
knockdown cells treated with tgf beta
we see a decrease in the fret ratio
which means an
increase in tension as i just showed you
with the tgf beta
above but then if we have the lpp
knocked down we don't see this change
and we don't see a response and a change
in tension in the adhesions
after growth factor treatment these bars
are an average of the tension
per adhesion if we look at the average
over each shell
we see the same phenotype that we see a
decrease in the fret ratio or an
increase in tension
in the control cells but when lpp is
knocked down we don't see that
changing tension these experiments
were done by an undergraduate in the lab
working with alex kupass
alex zawakowski
so if we look at images corresponding to
that data i just showed you
you can see in the control cells the lpp
knockdown cells
and the lpp knockdown cells with tgf
beta that we have a lot of blue
adhesions so these are corresponding to
low tension
or high fret whereas in the tgf beta
treated cells
in the presence of lpp you can see a lot
more adhesions that have red
or green yellow moderate to high tension
so we're seeing those cells are able to
respond to
the glow factor whereas the lpp
knockdown cells do not
so can that phenotype be rescued with
the delta abd lpp
so again we can see with the wild type
cells if we have the knockdown cells and
we put in
egfp wild types similar to the
endogenous we see a decrease in the
front ratio or an increase in tension
whereas when we try to rescue with the
delta abd lcp
for the lpp that can't find the actin
cytoskeleton
you can see that we don't see a response
and we actually see a slight
increase in the front ratio or decrease
in tension
which does show some statistical
significance although
we're working on getting some more data
for that condition
so basically the lpp has to be able to
bind to the actin cytoskeleton
in order for the adhesions to respond to
the
growth factor and have more tension
so another factor that that plays a role
in the progression of cancer
is the different tissues with different
biomechanical properties
so as i mentioned earlier women do not
die from breast cancer
they die from the metastatic cancer and
you can see from these numbers here that
at the time of death there's quite a
high rate of
cancer metastasis in the bone the liver
belongs in the brain
these tissues have very different
biomechanical properties so bone is very
hard and stiff
whereas brain is quite soft at about one
kilopascal
of uh sorry one pascal and one
kilopascal
of um stiffness and do these different
stiffnesses affect
the ability of breast cancer to
metastasize in those tissues
so it is known from fibroblast
mathematical models
and experiments that fibroblasts have a
certain stiffness where they move
optimally with the maximal speed and if
the surfaces are soft or hard the cells
do not move
as efficiently so we developed an
essay with the alan erlicker lab in
bioengineering at mcgill
using pdms substrates so these are a
polymer gel
and it can be very highly manipulated in
order to get very
defined stiffnesses of surface and then
the cells are plated on those surfaces
and the cell migration was measured
so if you look at the green curve here
you can see that when we
put lpp wild type in the knockdown cells
so lppgfp
we see something very similar to the
fibroblast where the cells move
optimally on about 40 kilopascal
surfaces
and on soft and hard surfaces they move
much more slowly
we also found that when we treat with
growth factor the cells can respond and
move faster
and this was independent of the
stiffness so we still see the general
trend with tgf beta
but the cells in general move faster on
all surfaces
however if the lpp is knocked down the
cells no longer sense the stiffness of
the surface
and they move at the same speed on all
of the surfaces
but taken together all of this data
really suggests that ltp is acting as a
mechanosensor
it's required for tgf beta induced
increases in cell migration and
inhibition dynamics
it's required for the formation of high
tension adaptations in response to
growth factor
it needs to be localized to the adhesion
and bind to the actin cytoskeleton for
these functions
and if we use the delta lpp delta abd
mutant which can't bind a reactant
cytoskeleton
the cells are unable to respond to the
growth factor
and lpp is required to sense and respond
to substrates with different mechanical
properties
so we're also interested in even in beta
podia so so far i've talked to you about
cell movement until migration but the
cells have to invade
surrounding tissues in order to leave
the breast
tissue and they need to invade tissues
at sites of metastasis
so the primary structure known to play a
role in this process
is the invadopodia and this structure
pushes
down into the tissue matrix metallic
proteases can digest the tissue
and then the active cytoskeleton plays a
role in creating
a force in order to push through the
tissue
and allow the cell to invade
but the question was is lpp involved in
this process
so for this part of the project a recent
masters student graduate from the lab
elena vurand who was in my lab as well
as
dr sakosam i developed this assay
using gelatin so basically what you do
is you
put down a fluorescent gelatin layer on
a
microscope cover glass and you have a
fluorophore on that gelatin so you have
a nice uniform layer and when you put
the cells down on that surface
if they undergo invasion then they
digest and push out of the way
and break down the gelatin so that you
get dark
areas on a bright background and this uh
these
surfaces can be characterized again we
use the surface feature and amaris in
order to do that
so you can see here the actin staining
so it's effective fluid and staining
lcp and focal adhesions and then you can
see the
invasion spots from
these two cells
so again we looked at the impact of tgf
data on invasions so
in the control cells we do see some
invasive spots
but when we treat with tgf data the
cells are significantly more invasive
if we quantify that you can see that the
cells without growth factor treatment
are much less in beta invasive than
following
growth factor treatment and this was a
challenging assay and challenging to
quantify as well
so we settled on looking at the total
surface area degraded per field of view
so we tried to find areas that have
similar numbers of cells
and look at the percentage of the area
that field of view
that was dark
so is lpp important for this so this is
showing another example
of cells expressing lpp where we have
minus
m plus tgf beta and again you can see
that increase in invasiveness with the
growth factor
and you can also see that here in the
quantification
however if we put in the lpp knockdown
cells
the cells are unable to respond to the
growth factor and the invasiveness does
not increase
so it looks like that invasion and
degradation of the gelatin
in response to growth factor is
dependent on the presence of lpp
so you're interested in combining the
invasion assay with the
biomechanics or substrate stiffness so
in this experiment we have the glass
coverslip
we put the pdms layer similar to the
cell migration experiments
and then we add gelatin on top so we
have the three layers
and we can look at the degradation of
the gelatin on surfaces of different
stiffness
so here you can see the gelatin stain
the actin staining and then the overlay
and what we found is that on very hard
surfaces there's a lot of invasions
on moderately stiff surfaces not so much
and on soft surfaces
somewhere in the intermediate again we
quantified that over a number of
different experiments with 154 fields of
view
and we saw something uh almost the
reverse of what we saw with migration
that the invasion was very high on stiff
surfaces and very high on soft surfaces
but in the intermediate surfaces the
invasion was much slower
so if we combine those two pieces of
data then what we find is that cell
migration is maximized on
moderately stiff or intermediate
stiffness around 40
kilopascal whereas invasion is higher on
soft surfaces
and hard surfaces so it's very um
possible that lpp is playing a role in
regulating
that when the surface is a intermediate
stiffness the cells are going to move
but if it's soft or hard they're going
to focus on invading the tissue
so i'm just going to give you one last
experiment that was really quite
interesting and it's it's preliminary
but
i thought it was quite interesting and
wanted to present it here today
so we looked at biophysical conditioning
of the cells and this was done
with the sql lab so what they did is
they
inject breast cancer cells into the
brain
of mice and leave them for three weeks
and then following the three weeks the
cells are isolated
and they're either put directly on
surfaces to look at invasions so this is
called exvival
or they're taken for one week and
conditioned on a plastic surface so a
relatively hard
plastic surface and we have what we call
ex-vivo plastic
at the same time we have another set of
the same cells that were not put into
the mouse
that are left in tissue culture on
plastic for the entire duration
and then imaged in the same assay
so the acids as i've just shown a few
slides ago
where we have a pdmf surface of
different stiffness on a glass coverslip
and then we have the gelatin layer
on which the cells are plated
so this figure is fairly busy but i'll
walk you through it and i think you'll
get the the general idea
so when we take the x-vivo cells the
um cells are not very invasive at all so
these cells have come out of very soft
brain tissue the brain tissue is around
one kilopascal
and the cells are not very invasive at
all when we do put them on a glass
surface
with um with the pdm without pdms sorry
just directly on the glass we put the
gelatin
then we we do see quite a bit of
invasiveness
however if the cells are put on on the
plastic dishes for a week and
reconditioned on this hard surface
then they tend to be invasive on all
surfaces of all stiffness
similarly the cells that were on the
plastic dish that were never put into
the mouth
are highly invasive on all surfaces
so this data was quantified and i'll
just mention again this is preliminary
data so it's a single
experimental run and i just want to
point out that the scaling here is quite
different on the three graphs
just for your information so the x vivo
cells really don't invade much at all
the
the total surface area degraded is only
going up to a 3000 here
although they do form invadopodia on the
glass surface
this is around an average of about 800
surface area the xvivoplastic you can
see is
is going up to 1500 so this is
significantly higher
and you can see a very similar trend to
it i showed you with the
other cell line that the cells tend to
invade maximally on soft and hard
surfaces
and are a little bit less invasive on
moderate stiffness
if you look at the cells that stayed on
the hard plastic surface for the entire
duration you can see the scale here is
50
000 so these are much more invasive than
the other two
conditions and you can see that the the
levels are quite high
across the um the difference thicknesses
we don't see the same clear trend that
we see here at the ex
vivoplastic but we're working on uh
doing the
experiment a few more times to validate
that
so overall um this shows that cells can
be conditioned so by moving to different
environments
they adapt to the environment they're in
and by being on a hard surface they tend
to
be able to adapt in order to invade
surfaces
of all different biomechanical
properties
so i just want to wrap up with another
short story
which is not related to breast cancer
but i think is
very important for all life cell imaging
and you'll notice in the whole breast
cancer project we did a lot of
live imaging under all the different
conditions and
we've been working on live imaging and
photo toxicity in my lab for quite a
long time
and recently discovered an issue that
we were aware of but not really aware of
the magnitude of the problem
so this work was recently published in
the journal of health science
and you can read all the details there i
just want to give you a little bit of a
snapshot
because i think this problem is probably
quite um
ubiquitous and i think most people are
not aware of it so
i think it's important
so when we do fluorescence imaging and
including the experiments that i've
shown you
here on focal adhesions and gelatin and
degradation and so on
there's a process we have to go through
so we need to open the shutter to expose
the sample to light
we need to turn on the light source
expose the sample to light and collect
an image
and then we have to turn off the light
source and or close the shutter
save the image and then repeat the
process so as we do the time lapse
imaging we
go around this circuit multiple times so
the key steps are
are opening the shutter turning on the
light source and then
closing the shutter and turning off the
light source and all shuttering is not
the same
so you can have a mechanical shredder if
you have like a mercury
a xenon or a metal halide source the
source stays on all the time and you
have a mechanical shutter that opens and
closes
to exposure sample to light for
fluorescence imaging
or you can have electronic control so
with led light sources you can have usb
control from the image acquisition
software or you can have direct ttl
electronic triggering from the camera
and as i mentioned it's really important
to know that all shuttering is not the
same
but the reason this problem came to our
attention is we were working on some
experiments to systematically look at
how the
incident light power of the lamp and the
exposure time
were playing a role in phototoxicity if
at all
and what we found is when we use high
incident light power
and short exposure time so 24
milliseconds here
the cells were not very dynamic at all
so these rose plots are showing fairly
short
um cell tracks however when we use the
long exposure time with low light power
we did find that the cells moved quite
significantly and these matched up
really well with our bright field
imaging
where we wouldn't expect any sort of
toxicity so initially we thought that
the reason
the the cells were not moving while at
high power was just because of the power
of the light
so the cells were seeing a lot of
photons in a short amount of time
but we found out after that that was not
the case
so we used an oscilloscope to actually
measure the shuttering
of our light source and we had three
different settings that we looked at
so in all cases the software was set for
a 24 millisecond camera exposure
and in the first case the light was
turned on and off using a ttl
trigger so this is a cable which
basically goes directly from the camera
to the light source
and sends a signal from the camera
saying i'm ready to collect
light and collect an image and in this
case we had no what we call illumination
overhead
the shutter really opened and closed or
the lamp turned on and off
in 24 milliseconds however in the
experiment i just showed you we had been
using the usb connection because that
gives us the ability
to control the light source using the
image acquisition software and what we
found there is this red curve
and when we were actually doing a 24
millisecond image acquisition
the light was actually on for 137
milliseconds or almost six times the
exposure time
if you're using a mechanical shutter
this is a physical shutter that needs to
open and close
and in that case we found it took about
230 milliseconds
or 10 times the exposure time so these
delays are termed
illumination overhead where the sample
is exposed to light
but the detector is not collecting
an image and
these these delays are linked both to
software and hardware
so in the mechanical shutter it
physically has to open and close
in the usb light we know that the led
can turn on very rapidly
so there must be other potential
software delays
playing a role there so we would factor
a cell migration experiment and this is
the data i already showed you where at
high incident light power the cells
don't move very well
and when we were sure that the sample
was being
illuminated with the ttl triggering so
that it was only illuminated for 24
milliseconds for each image
then we did see cell tracks that were
very similar to the
long exposure time low light levels so
the effect that we were seeing was
actually due to this illumination
overhead
in this case we had the usb signaling
going and so there was some kind of
software delay that was allowing the
light to stay on
about six times longer
so this is another example just showing
you what can happen in the lysol
experiment
so on the left side we have low power
and long exposure time
and we're looking at cells expressing
paxil and gfp
also stained with mitre tracker red and
you can see that the cells are very
dynamic
and the mitochondria are moving around
and fusing
and diffusing and everything looks quite
good this is four hours of imaging
taking an image every minute
and taking an image of the mitre tracker
every six minutes
on the right side we have the high power
short exposure time
and this was collected with the usb
signaling so we know that we have about
five times the amount of light
on the sample then we expect i'm sure
almost six times
and you can see here that the
mitochondria very early on start to
condense and the cell starts to round up
and eventually
the cell likely dies and disappears from
the field of view
you can see the importance of of this
illumination overhead and how it can
really drastically affect the
phototoxicity
so the best thing to do is trigger your
light source directly with the ttl
and this is only possible if you have a
solid state source so an led based light
source or a solid state laser
you can also measure the elimination
overhead because we found there's all
kinds of differences depending on the
exposure time you said
and the frame rate even the delay
between images can affect
the elimination overhead and for
bulb-based systems where you have to use
a mechanical shutter and you can't do
direct triggering
it's best to use the lower power and
longer exposure time
that would be similar to this condition
so that you can image yourselves for a
long period of time
without the effect of toxicity
so as i mentioned that's just a bit of a
snapshot and all the details are in
the publication but i really think it's
important that people are aware of this
phenomena
and adapt their lifestyle imaging
conditions for it
we observed it also in our spinning disc
confocal
which had a software delay as well even
though it had solid state layers
laser sorry so i'd like to thank
the members of my lab i mentioned the
people who worked on the project as i
was going along
and also the advanced bio imaging
facility staff all of the
imaging was done in our facility at
mcgill
so i mentioned the students in my lab
our collaborators
peter siegel is really the lab that
initiated the ltp project
and i've been really excited working
with them
trying to get at the molecular level and
look at live cell imaging
and alan erlicker's lab has worked with
us for all of the
pdms and substrate stiffness experiments
and thank you of course to all of our
funding agencies
without them this work wouldn't be
possible and i thank you for your
attention and
look forward to answering any questions
hi claire that was a great talk
um i'm so glad that you shared the
the work you guys did looking at the
photo toxicity i think it's such an
important story for everyone to hear
and those early results are super
tantalizing
um so yes thank you again
um i uh i do have a
uh some questions um when you're in the
audience
good i do have some questions from um
the audience
so let's get started with those
a lot of the work that you showed uh was
of cells migrating in 2d does this
have relevance in vivo
so um i know a lot of uh there's a lot
of debate in the field about about
the experiments that are done on on flat
glass surfaces but there are a lot of
surfaces in the biology
um including like the basement membrane
sometimes cells will move along
blood vessels so that's kind of like a
rolling or folded
two-dimensional surface and even
movement along collagen fibers people
have modeled as more of a
one-dimensional migration where the
cells are moving
along almost like a rope or a cable
so i do think it has some role to play
in
in the natural environment of the cell
okay yeah i hadn't thought about
collagen
as a as a 1d thing that's cool
um sort of along the same lines do you
have plans to explore the role of lpp
and regulating cell migration and more
physiological
uh environments so we have um
some data where we've been looking at
the cells on top of
uh three-dimensional surfaces so rather
than using the pdms which is
really a chemical uh material that we've
that you know that has been developed
we put the cells on top of things like
bovine collagen or
rat tail collagen that are that are more
physiological relevant
and we are working on assays now to look
at single cells
and spheroids in three-dimensional
gels the um sample prep and so on is
actually quite challenging to get
reproducibility and
and have the cells moving and and
migrating
in a systematic way and then the
microscopy in that case we're working
with both spinning discs and
light sheet imaging so we can image fast
enough
to see the processes
you mentioned pdms um
how how hard is it to make
all those diff the series of different
stiffnesses and the
in the pdms um
so we did that in collaboration with
alan erlicker's group and
some really tremendous bioengineers in
his lab
um it's super tricky and
alanna has graduated so i'm hoping that
we'll be able to maintain it in the lab
but it's um yeah it's a lot of trial and
error there's a lot of chemical steps
some of the steps for cleaning the
surface there's a reagent called piranha
so of course you want to make sure you
don't have any piranha left by the time
you put your cells down
we had issues with drying out and
cracking and then trying to put the
gelatin
on top you you have a another interface
um where the gelatin can peel off or or
you know wrap over on itself and so on
so
um so i think we have it down to a
pretty good protocol but i think
you know kudos to the students for
persisting because it
uh the results are fabulous but the the
troubleshooting is pretty intense so
yeah we wouldn't know it from what
you've shown
um let's see so
another another thing is that there's
you're showing a lot of data on
individual cells or individual adhesions
do you have a plan to perform more
advanced
data analytics really rather than just
looking at averages
so this is a direction my lab's really
been moving to
in the last i would say year or so i
have a post-doc now who's a
computer scientist who's got a lot of
expertise in deep learning and machine
learning
and we're starting to apply things like
unsupervised learning with
like hierarchical clustering and
bioinformatics that are used
more in genomics but are starting to be
applied more in imaging
and uh it's really fascinating um we're
seeing like
you know you might have a treatment and
90 of the cells respond but there's just
10
that don't and now we're interested like
what's going on with that 10 percent
and i guess eventually um it's not
really my area of expertise but you
could also imagine
doing like single cell rna-seq and and
really trying to tease out how come
those cells
you know respond differently and i am
was at a seminar years ago and and uh it
was a really cute story that the speaker
talked about uh school buses and that if
you were
looking from space and studying school
buses on the earth you would conclude
that they aggregate in big groups
and they don't move and unless you
actually happen
you know at six in the morning or three
in the afternoon you'd never see that
and so it's always kind of stuck with me
that
maybe the the things we're always seeing
are not the most interesting so
yeah yeah oh that's cool i look forward
to
hearing more about all of that um and
i want to make sure that we have a
question talking about
the the second half for the second part
um of what you presented today
so um you were talking about
illumination
overhead and this concept of making sure
you're thinking about
all of the illumination that's going to
the sample and
so how big of a problem or how how broad
of a problem do you think this
is for everyone so we were super
surprised i was
pretty sure that this was due to the
light power
and i'd always thought that there's just
more photons hitting the cell really
quickly
and i didn't i knew that there was
issues with the timing but i didn't
really think it was
the only thing going on and it really
seems from our data that it's
the major effect is is from this effect
and it's really complicated we've done
more experiments
and we find it on spinning discs so even
though our
our laser is triggered um electronically
it's a solid state laser we still have
the 17 millisecond delay between images
that we can't really explain
and so if you're working with high
intensity and short exposure times that
17 milliseconds is really significant
um so what our approach now is we're
actually working on a protocol paper on
how to measure
it because it took us a long time to
figure out how to measure it properly
and then i think one of the things i'd
really like to do is just bring
awareness to people
because i think most people don't know
about it and there are fixes so once you
know it's there
it's a lot easier to fix it so i think
we've been trying to talk to the
microscope
vendors and core facilities and just get
the word out
um to just be aware of this if you're
doing uh
live imaging but that being said i think
it's also important for fixed cells you
can imagine if you're doing
high-resolution z-stack and trying to do
deconvolution it's photobleaching as
you're going
but you're really you know throwing away
all this light which you don't have to
be if you
if you're um you know more in tune with
us
um we had another question come in
um given what you've learned about the
light dosing are you trying to account
for that when
imaging through the pdms and the gelatin
because they have different optical
properties
um so it's it is tricky imaging through
those
the experiments i showed you with the
the pdms and the gelatin are actually
done on laser scanning confocal because
we have to
have the signal to noise through that
thick surface so they're actually
difficult to do on a wide field
so usually with laser scanning confocal
you don't have to worry about the
overhead illumination because
these are triggered instantaneously
pretty much with
acoustic optics but i do think the power
density then starts to play a role
because you've got the light focused
into this little tiny spot
with a lot of photons so you do have to
play around a bit with scan speed
and intensity of the light and and so on
to be sure that
you're minimizing photo toxicity on that
platform as well
okay okay i think we'll wrap up with
questions but
um there's one other thing that we
wanted to talk about
claire has mentioned how she's
publishing and making sure that other
core facilities
and that sort of thing know about this
overhead problem and you're performing
what i see is a really nice service to
the community
and other ways that you are serving the
community is taking part in these
other organizations and so you along
with allison north are
co-chairs of the bio imaging north
america
group and i think you wanted to talk
just a little bit about that and make
sure everybody knows about it
so yeah i'll let you do that yeah so
it's it's a recent
group we founded it about two years ago
and
the idea is to just bring the community
together
to build consensus around different
things to build awareness
the focus of the group right now is
working groups so we have working groups
on quality control and standards
we're in the process of forming a new
group on image analysis
we have a diversity and inclusion group
and
we also have a communications group and
we're looking to
to form more as the the group grows and
the sort of the
um way that we've been forming those
working groups is getting people who are
not part of the executive
to take a lead and we've been bringing
in a lot of younger
researchers who are just starting up
core facilities and
and i think bringing building the
building the community and they're
bringing along
their peers and and so on and for
instance with the quality control and
standards group we're working on getting
a consensus
of how to measure quality control on a
comp vocal
and then we want to present that to the
community and try to come up with a
consensus on you know the best way to
measure resolution or
or laser stability and things like that
so i think it's going to be a tremendous
tool for the community
we also plan we've applied for funding
from the nsf
and we're hoping to get money which will
be focused
completely on core facility scientists
so
it'll be for travel to meetings for job
shadowing
when we can get back to traveling and um
and just uh again just building up that
expertise and really recognizing the
imaging scientists
who are working in facilities and and
helping you know
the whole community of of labs working
in
areas like cell and developmental
biology yes so
um so next week we actually have an
event um
three weeks ago we had an event looking
at personal protective equipment
and and how to open facilities safely
and
we've published those guidelines that
kind of came out of the meeting
on the royal microscopy society website
and we're having a follow-up meeting
next wednesday june 10th on
ways to manage users
and we're going to have some of the
the companies that are working with core
facility management software
i know for me i have like three or four
microscopes in some rooms so we're going
to have to make sure we don't have
too many people accessing the room at
the same time
how do we prioritize people and so on so
so that's next
wednesday in collaboration with uk bio
imaging and
and the raw microscopy society so i
would encourage people to to join in the
conversation and
we're all learning from each other so
anybody has any great ideas we'd love to
hear them
it's all new for all of us right so
yeah well thank you again for taking
part in that and really
sort of yeah providing
some really nice resources to the entire
community and i think everyone
does appreciate it and i very much
appreciate you
taking part in our meeting and
presenting this keynote
it was great um and thank you to
everyone
that has uh watched us and will watch us
so these will be around for a year um so
if you haven't been able to catch
a keynote or one of the other um
talks that's out there they will be
within this in virtual environment for a
whole year
um so you have some time and yeah
uh we'll make sure that the other
questions that came in from claire
came in for claire that she gets those
as well too so
thanks again to everyone thanks claire
thank you
take care everybody